un retroceso de décadas en materia de
derechos humanos en la región es lo que
denuncia human rightswatch en su informe
anual
en américa latina estamos enormemente
preocupados no sólo por las dictaduras
puras y duras como lo son nicaragua cuba
venezuela sino porque hay varios casos
de líderes que fueron electos
democráticamente y que una vez en el
poder hacen caso omiso a las garantías
más elementales de la democracia y se
dedican a ir en contra de la
independencia judicial de la prensa
independiente de el trabajo de la
sociedad civil
según el organismo uno de los casos más
extremos es el de yair bolsonaro en
brasil además de difundir mentiras
relacionadas con la pandemia el
mandatario brasileño ha atacado a la
rama judicial y en pleno año de
elecciones ha cuestionado la validez del
sistema electoral
este primer mensaje es que nosotros las
instituciones democráticas y la
comunidad internacional estaremos muy
alertas durante este año que es un año
electoral para que no haya intentos de
romper este proceso democrático de
quitar el derecho fundamental al voto de
todos los brasileños y el debilitamiento
del estado democrático de derecho
y la libertad de prensa preocupa
igualmente human rightswatch recalca los
ataques a la credibilidad de los medios
de comunicación independientes en el
salvador justo el periódico 'el faro'
denuncia que sus periodistas fueron
interceptados por el gobierno ofrecimos
pruebas de que el gobierno del
presidente en la ibu que él está
negociando con la mara salvatrucha 13 y
con las dos facciones del barrio 18
durante todo ese proceso el programa
pegasus estuvo espiando mi teléfono en
cuanto a nicaragua se dice que las
pasadas elecciones presidenciales se
llevaron a cabo sin las mínimas
garantías democráticas denuncia los
abusos policiales en las protestas de
2021 en colombia la represión del
disenso en cuba y la alta tasa de
impunidad de las repetidas violaciones a
los derechos humanos en méxico